i've come to the end of my week in
vietnam
and it's been a culinary trip into the
unknown and the unthinkable
ah [ __ ]
my mentor v said one week would not be
enough to master this cuisine and i'm
about to find out if she was right
i'm in hanoi to cook a dinner for v and
other top tutors i've met this week
mr rice
hi sir oh yeah good to see you how are
you doing yeah well thank you this place
looks amazing let me show you around
here please it looks beautiful
missy's duck's friend mr rice has given
me the use of his fine dining restaurant
a success is built on authentic
vietnamese cooking and so it's a great
honor
the rush is beautiful yeah thank you who
designed it i desire myself good job
worryingly for me mr rice has invited
along 30 discerning diners
you got a huge huge challenge and you
know tonight so many people here just
waiting for your cooking and i say about
six seven people very tough ready in
three hours the restaurant will be full
and i need to quickly get used to these
unfamiliar surroundings
well this is the kitchen yeah
so everything here tonight's yours yeah
gas burners and
grill
um
completely different layout of a kitchen
not like working with a gas ring burner
um ten times more powerful a lot more
instant so uh
on the fly yet again
tonight my menu will be drawn on
everything i've learned i'm cooking pig
seven ways so starting off with the pork
and shrimp um fresh spring roll yeah
yeah we served at room temperature be
very careful
uh pig's ear salad blanched in a nice
sort of spicy broth uh barbecued pork
skewer and it's drilled over charcoal
then we're going to go to the sweet and
sour pork ribs okay after that we've got
the pigsta curry after that caramelized
pork belly finished with fish sauce
after that the pork noodle broth let's
go
bye-bye
my nose to town menu is a tall order i
start with barbecue pork skewers
inspired by missy's duck
the shoulder of pork
sliced thinly
marinated
and then cooked on
charcoal
now that doesn't look
anywhere near like missy's ducks
it's times like this i wish you'd just
give me the recipe properly i think it's
secretly because she had a massive crush
on me
and she had visions of her and i set up
a restaurant together
next for my pig feast a curry that i
hope will satisfy the vietnamese
appetite for texture
normally when we use trotters at home in
the uk we bone them out and stuff them
but
these are
cooked
on the bone and very gelatinous
nice
fresh turmeric
a little bit of garlic ginger fish sauce
a little bit of fermented rice wine
vinegar
almost like a sort of light spicy curry
the pressure is on and already i've made
my first mistake so this is my broth
remember my singing ordeal down the
river i'm just struggling for that nice
sort of
lightly sort of pinkish color
i'm beginning to wish i'd kept things
simple
i've got one dish
seared out [ __ ] 400 things to do
[ __ ] out
downstairs hanoi's most accomplished
foodies have arrived
along with my mentors mrs duck
and madame v
all here to pass judgement on my efforts
i think it's a big challenging for him
because something completely new
and very different to what you have at
home
bee's premonition is coming true i'm
having a kitchen nightmare i know the
broth's gone cloudy so i turned up the
gas and by rapidly reducing down some
strength it's gone cloudy here
are the sweetness our ribs i want to put
them in the oven
but they don't have ovens here so
everything's going to be cooked on top
okay pour trotters broth
ribs i think now he's in control he's in
control now because it's no salty no
yearling from the kitchen yes
oh [ __ ] how
[ __ ]
bollocks
oh [ __ ]
that'd kill me if you saw it
watch out please guys come on yo go out
of the way please everybody everybody
the spectators
by now i should be serving up but i'm
nowhere near ready skewers please
okay
yeah i need color on there i need color
come on please yeah charcoal that's what
gives a color let's go
[Music]
it's gone 7 30 and hanoi's finest have
been waiting to eat for over half an
hour
i think in 20 minutes to be here all the
foods will be here i
should run up to the kitchen and kick
him
ass
i'm starving
i need to eat something and then unless
you know i'm waiting for a long time
skewers please
turn them over turn over more color
please come on hero
yeah
finally my dishes come together
the broth is nice and clear now i've
clarified it
some minced pork and egg white to get it
nice and clear
my homage to missy's duck is almost
ready to be served
fingers crossed madame duck style
sesame seed
and at the last minute i've put together
my pig's ear salad don't take anything
until i say don't take anything till
they're [ __ ] finished please
okay let's go please
gently gently gently gently no no no no
look no stop yeah that one goes on there
right you come here stand here one bowl
hold the tray tight
yep and two let's go
[Music]
at last dinner is served
this has been one of the toughest nights
of my cooking career
[Music]
i think what i want to say is this is
very brave
that was a nightmare
struggled
um across the whole three hours i'd like
to think i'd done it justice but
i left myself a little bit short
[Music]
but my ordeal isn't over yet i need to
face my mentors to find out if i've
impressed them
how are you doing recognize you with no
hats on how are the pig sweaters um
i'm i'm i'm not fan of that damn what a
shame i think it's a little too much
caramel sauce ready too sweet for you
yeah wow i like you uh i like the pizza
or the pizza yeah it's beautiful
it's so crunchy i love that passion
chewy crunchy crispy
soft and silky got it the the pork
chocha the pig trotter is perfect
pigs is the most difficult meat to cook
so it's really really impressive what
you have done
with that the text is too strong
and the color is too dark
i think it's very difficult to do very
authentic
i think this one
i can eat it for no problem madame look
at you finally i want to know what the
dying of nose-to-tail cooking things of
my efforts oh my goodness me what
happened huh
that's amazing
before you before you have basically
been very pleased yes the best the real
soda on skewers on the charcoal
well if it wasn't for you this shoulder
wouldn't have tasted as good as it did
trust me i'm so glad that you like that
one
i'm gonna say
good to see you mr ice as always so
vietnamese people is very hard to please
so but tonight gordon
i think he does well
he pass it
for me
one of the most thrilling seven days
i've ever spent in my cooking career
honestly
if you want to eat well get rid of your
fridge it forces you to buy ingredients
twice a day and cook in a completely
different way
challenging week yet for me
one of the most inspirational big time
crispy crunchy chewy soft and silky
right
airport
i've escaped to vietnam and promised one
of the best cooks in the country that
i'll get to grips with this unique
cuisine in just a week
[Music]
i'm hot footing out of ho chi minh city
and flying 1500 kilometers north to the
capital hanoi
it's a huge learning curve for me it'd
be very ignorant from a chess point of
view not to embrace
their understanding
of their waste nothing and the
everything
hanoi is a communist stronghold
traditionally this part of the country
has a no waste culture
they are experts in nose-to-tail eating
and one the taurus female chef has made
a reputation cooking just one ingredient
[Music]
now this lady's a bit of a hard ass bit
of a legend i'm in hanoi for two days
and i'm here for inspiration i'm gonna
get in there see what she's up to and
hopefully yeah like a magpie steal some
ideas what she's doing
jesus
where's the boss
hello how are you
good to see you what's up jayden
uh jordan
um your name man luckily for me a local
restaurant owner has come to my rescue
madame quack
h o i oh man
of course you said quack duck
quack quack quack and you are my my
name's rice call me quan
mr rice and mrs duck yes so where's mr p
king
yeah
i don't want to piss her off yeah i want
to keep on a good side all right yeah i
heard she has a ferocious temper that's
it all right three cleavers by the side
of her
very sad very sad yeah yeah how many
ducks a day does she sell
how many husbands have she killed uh
one
missy ducker spent 30 years perfecting
her menu but before i get to taste it
she wants me to meet her key ingredient
out back
what are these little babies here how
old are they
they must be days old uh
about 10 days ten days old how old are
these
four months or five minutes four months
old so which ones we're gonna use first
this is the oldest one
and this one
in order to find the plumpest bird mrs
duck has devised a unique test
why are we done can you can you hear the
sound yeah yeah drama the duck to the
ground yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but i'm quite
never touched just listen just put this
down all right so she's waiting she's
listening for a weighted yeah heavy
sounds
that sounds good
i'm beginning to think missy's duck is
quackers
but her dish is famous throughout hanoi
so she must be doing something right
so this is how she prepares a duck every
day yes and
it's important to bleed the ducks
otherwise it's going to spoil the
texture of the meat i get that but why
is she cutting it there
because
here just stay away from the stomach you
may get the bad food from stomach into
the plant yes yeah she believes in
slaughtering them
just before she started cooking them so
he's done that fresh does it all the way
fresh like that just close it and then
cook
yes yes houses and everything
the duck is the the the goddess of her
house the duck is the goddess of the
house he says
very quick
anything to keep her happy
now the dirty work is over missy's duck
wants to give me a lesson in
nose-to-tail butchery
straight down in the middle yeah pass
the cleaver to her see one that takes
you hot she wants she wants to now teach
me how to sharpen a knife
yeah this is duck
yeah straight off okay off
yep
it's amazing i've never actually
slaughtered one in the kitchen
taking this feathers off
and butchered it from there
is there anything of the duck that she
never uses you see that yeah other
glands that's the bile the bile very
bitter yeah if that bursts over the duck
it ruins the texture
no it's smelly
i'm enjoying myself i'm about to learn
mrs duck's sweet and sour sauce
but all of a sudden she's become
tight-lipped
so nobody knows this recipe values
nobody knows okay her life so not easy
to give her life i'm not asking to marry
her i'm asking for the recipe it's you
and i
look at me this is duck missy's stuff um
why are you being such a hard house yeah
when i've just plucked your ducks she'll
tell you even her husband doesn't know
about that serious
oh my god you
huh
you're one-off she's unique she's like a
fine bottle of wire and they only
produce one bottle of weed
she's amazing
huge source of inspiration
more importantly she knows her stuff i
mean big time so she hasn't focused on
25 30 dishes she's just focused on a
unique way with duck
she shows no mercy straight in there
nothing squeamish about missy's duck is
there
a little bit [ __ ] scared to be honest
while her signature dish cooks i'm gonna
sample the rest of mrs duck's menu
so many different ways different
sort of stars of cooking the duck it's
amazing do you want to try the hat if
you want to ah
easier
nice and tender that's good
that's very good
that's the
that's nice it's got a leathery liver
texture to it
now for the main event the bbq duck is
ready
it says mix with the marinade and then
on top of the charcoal grill that's
great and then the fan obviously to
intensify the heat yeah okay
nice
that is delicious
and she's managed to use
everything
even there as a piece of the leg it's
it's amazing
you